foresaw six a new director was brought
onto the series and just like all of his
predecessors Kevin Groot eart was a
first time director though he did have
experience with the franchise having
edited movies 1 through 5 on his title
card there's some flashing effect going
on with the letters VI highlighting the
Roman numerals for the sixth installment
there would be a lot of sixes that come
up in this film like the fact that
John's instructions for his ex-wife come
in six envelopes the inclusion of six
new traps the dog pit which was a group
of six insurance policy inspectors who
were all tested in the Carousel trial
and according to IMDB the soundtrack is
EPS six has a length of six minutes and
is played in the background over the
final six-minute climax scene before the
credits roll hard to say if that last
one is really intentional but even with
all of the sixes found in this movie
there's an even more important seven and
I'm not talking about mr. Feldman's line
when he gives the box to Jill I'm just
tired what's in the box I'm talking
about a new 7 that hints to the audience
that the next sequel will be the last of
this saga so stick around to the end of
this video if you want to hear about it
welcome to things you missed I think so
6 is probably the most underrated movie
in the franchise we get to see jigsaw
explore some new territory as the film
makes a statement about the health
insurance system in the United States it
was a topic of discussion in 2009 when
saw six came out just five months before
the Affordable Care Act also known as
Obamacare was passed and it may be an
even bigger topic of discussion as I'm
recording this video in the year 2020 as
the world is going through the biggest
global health threat of the past century
many of the traps and saw six are
symbolic of the position that health
care providers have to take when
considering coverage for a clients there
are also some disturbing things you may
have missed outside of that but I'm not
allowed to say them until after the logo
that actually doesn't make sense cuz I
already said some things you missed at
the beginning of this video but our
opening trap features a couple of
malicious moneylenders who plans to
repossess more than their payees could
ever pay back and honestly this one
never made sense to me because it's
completely unfair the rules state that
whoever offers the most flesh onto the
scale will be the one to survive and the
woman Simone has considerably less flesh
to give she's at a disadvantage because
she's healthy
as for jigsaws motto she cherished her
life more and yet she's being punished
for it
still
if I was in the trap I would have put
all my clothes on the scale first it's
not like this movie isn't already rated
R we are then introduced to the umbrella
health company I think this is less of a
Resident Evil homage and more of a
reference to the purpose of an umbrella
to cover you just as an insurance
company offers coverage but this company
is very particular about who they're
willing to cover and has a team of
policy inspectors checking up on people
to make sure that they're at a low risk
to actually get sick they sit around a
circular table in the middle of the
office whose shaped resembles the
carousel trap that they would eventually
be placed on this team is referred to as
the dog pit and the top dog is Dave who
isn't a ward on his desk that says
terminator of them all this is obviously
a reference to the termination of
insurance plans but looking back on it
with more context gives it a darker
meaning where it seems to be about the
termination of human life terminator
strikes again the boss William Easton
works with his lawyer on a deposition
about a man named Harold Abbott's the
father of a family who would eventually
give the final judgement of William you
remember dealing with a mr. Harold
Abbott in his office mr. Easton has the
news broadcasting on the television
where the anchor talks about the
distribution of John Kramer's assets
after his death and she mentions that
most of them were in real estate which
may lend more credibility to the nerve
gas house theory that I mentioned in the
last episode of things amassed also the
news station is wnkw news if you lived
in North America around the heyday of
broadcast television you may be familiar
with the four character station ID is
given to every television and radio
station all stations east of the
Mississippi River were required to start
with EE I've given plenty of evidence
that the setting of the Saw movies is on
the East Coast throughout the series so
this is just one more factor in favor of
that idea another interesting aspect of
this office is the fish tank full of
piranhas which as far as I know are not
a common pet and are known for their
predatory behavior I think they're
symbolic of this company piranha good
job John you really know your fishies
after Williams capture he finds himself
in the mr. freaking pasta trap or maybe
we should just call it the preview of
2020 trap his opponent is the janitor
Hank a smoker who likely would not have
been able to acquire health insurance
according to umbrellas policy
only 52 years of age this man has
continued to smoke even though he has a
history of high blood pressure and heart
disease we eventually come to find out
that John chose mr. Easton for his game
because he once denied coverage for an
experimental cancer treatment tank is
the same age that John was when he died
and I feel like he was chosen to make a
statement about the insurance company's
power to in a way choose who lives and
who dies also this is the first time
John shows himself on screen during the
tapes where he explains the rules to his
victims and I think he did this to
remind William of the face he once
encountered when the two met at a party
at homeward-bound clinic it didn't
matter that John was giving away his
identity in this one because the
instructions for this game were
delivered to Jill in his will in other
words the trial of William Houston could
only take place after John's death which
i think is fitting because it makes
William realize the message that jigsaw
is trying to convey that because of his
policy the blood is figuratively on his
hands the trap assets victims to use his
little oxygen as possible whoever does
that can avoid being crushed by this
machine they've both got the wrong idea
here
in my experience with scuba diving the
best way to conserve air is to take slow
deep continuous breaths Williams faith
and his policy would be challenged again
in the next trap but first there would
be some interesting details of note in
the past of Jill too
you
after receiving the materials from
John's will Jill flashes back to some of
the memorable moments of her marriage
and its downfall we see the grave of
their unborn son and Gideon which
features an infinity icon perhaps to
symbolize John's belief in the idea of
rebirth he considers his test subjects
to be reborn whenever they passed one of
his traps it's not entirely clear if the
animals are connected to this in a
circle of life kind of way or if they
could be connected to the location of
his largest game which takes place at an
abandoned Zoo as far as horror movies
that take place in zoos go pretty good
track record William Easton continues
through his trial where he's reminded of
the party where he first met John Kramer
it would appear that Amanda a former
patient of the clinic is also present at
this party wearing the same outfit she
had on during the reverse beartrap scene
and saw wand - those detached leaves
I guess Amanda doesn't have that many
outfits because it's in an earlier
flashback she has the same shirt she had
on when she helps John set up the
bathroom Gaiman saw three but you can
tell by her hair that these things
aren't taking place on the same day the
next section of the zoo game took place
in what looks like a reptile habitat and
I have to wonder if Kevin Rooter saw
that one jump scare the year before in
the dark nights yeah that one and
basically thought you know what we're
gonna do that too just doesn't hit quite
the same though but I do like this trap
because it forces William to make
similar kind of life-or-death decisions
to those made in his work but it
personalizes them by using his own
employees as he killed a family woman
nearing the end of her life or a healthy
young man with no family his insurance
formula would have him cover the man
rather than the woman but in the heat of
the moment that's not what he decides as
you can see the choice is not so clear
when you are face-to-face with the
people whose blood will stain your
we revisit the moment Williams policy
personally affected John who had been
seeking health coverage to undergo an
experimental gene therapy for his cancer
from a Norwegian doctor he brings in a
pamphlet where we can see the name of
the doctor is Soren Papa skip that
happens to be the same name of the first
assistant art director whose name was
also seen on the box and the FBI
headquarters and saw five since I always
like to make up stories so that his
Easter eggs make sense in universe I'm
gonna say that dr. Papas key was on
vacation visiting the US or he happened
to be the victim of a crime when John's
coverage is denied he goes on a rant
about the empty promises of politicians
who claim that health related decisions
should be made by doctors and patients
he motions to the clip playing on the TV
screen which is a quick shot of John
McCain who was a senator who ran for
president in 2008 no I'm not gonna
pretend like I know anything about
politics but from what I can gather this
guy opposed Obama's health care plan
which came out in 2009 at the same year
that saw six was released
obviously the movie takes place in 2006
though not long after jigsaws death but
I imagine that McCain already had his
views about health care beforehand so
the meaning behind the clip is still
relevant room number three is the steam
nades where William had to guide his
lawyer through a dangerous labyrinth
filled with vapors hot enough to leave a
nasty burn come on man just climb over
the railing a little bit and pull the
lever from an angle where you don't have
to get burned you ever played Crash
Bandicoot these steam things can totally
be avoided he also gets kicked in the
balls and is fine two seconds later but
whatever let's go back to the FBI
storyline they figured out that there's
an abnormality in strahm's fingerprints
which they founded the crime scene of
the opening trap special agent Perez
shows Hoffman's screen with the analysis
report we see strahm's name above a few
others
Anthony iani is a new name crooks he's
the production designer on this movie
there are two other names that are not
new they're both first assistant art
directors but in the world of the movie
Shawn Scofield is an FBI agent and
possibly newspaper writer and Sauron
well we just discussed Sauron the
Norwegian doctor turns to risk crime
someone's gotta make a Saw movie or at
least a comic or something with all the
easter-egg characters as the main
characters just for my sake as the game
nears its end jill prepares her plan for
its conclusion and in her apartment
there are some photos of her and john
which seem to tell us the reason that
she's still willing to help him if she
keeps those pictures up after their
divorce it would seem that there are
still some feelings there also how old
were they when they got married I mean
the pictures are out of focus in the
background there but I mean look at that
hairline this marriage seems like it
might have been kind of recent the
biggest room of the zoo game features a
large spiral on both the door and on the
carousel itself the spiral has been a
symbol associated with both jigsaw and
build the puppet from the very beginning
which will presumably be explored more
in the 9th movie spiral to match mr.
easton's ratio where he rejects 2/3 of
Insurance applicants jigsaw asked him to
kill off 2/3 of his application review
team the trap resembles a carnival ride
he uses Billy for the tape this time
rather than footage of himself and with
his white face paint and cheeky bowtie
Billy kind of does resemble a carnie of
all the Billy videotapes this one might
be the creepiest not sure what it is the
carnival music that comes in when the
ride starts moving provides great
contrast with the sheer horror of the
scene it brings out the worst in each
employee because of their desperation to
live in the end mr. Easton goes full
idubbbz and Simpson staff down to two
women meanwhile the FBI has finished Dee
scrambling the tape from the pendulum
trap scene in the last movie and they
invite Hoffmann to see the results
you
detective Hoffman has no choice but to
go with Erickson and Perez to see the
results of The Voice descramble now as
an audio professional I don't think
that's a thing you can do the jigsaw
voice is made by layering together audio
with the various pitches so the FBI
could analyze different frequencies but
they'd have no way of knowing which one
was the original voice now normally I
don't talk about mistakes and just
accept the fact that it's a movie but I
mean come on this movie is directed by
an editor he should have caught that but
despite all of that I think this is
probably actually my favorite scene in
the Saw franchise and at the end of it
Hoffman is going to his car after taking
out three agents and we see this prompt
which looks like one of those chattering
teeth gags I don't know why this would
be here inside of this computer lab if
not to foreshadow the upcoming scene
this is essentially someone's jaw and I
think it's a sign that Hoffman's jaw is
about to get damaged in the Reverse bear
trap to point out but before heading
back to the zoo for the last part of
Williams trial Hoffman goes back into
the lab where Special Agent Erickson is
still alive and covers him in gasoline
Bruno just brutal when William makes it
to the final room he sees his sister
Pamela the jigsaw reporter condemned it
for her sensationalist writing but his
life ends up in the hands of the family
of Frank Abbott's the man who died as a
result of Umbrella health terminating
his insurance plan on a technicality
to
[Applause]
so far this is the only saw movie to
have a post credit scene where we see
Amanda circus ah three delivering a
message to Corbett den one don't trust
the one who saves you I've seen this
scene criticized in the past because we
never specifically see what comes of it
in South I of Corbett was rescued by
Hoffman and taking the safety and we
never see her again after that at least
not that we know of so what was the
meaning of the scene I think the
implication here is that after saving
Corbett she told agent Perez that some
woman warned her not to trust the one
that saves her so Perez was immediately
suspicious of Hoffman this is reflected
in this line after Perez is badly
injured by the exploding Billy the
puppets she said your name you know last
thing she said was detective Hoffman
why'd she say that why she said your
name then in saw six Prez is revealed to
have survived the attack but even after
supposedly determining that Strom was
the second accomplice Perez still
doesn't look too happy to see Hoffman I
think it all goes back to Corbett's
warning I really don't see how else they
would have had the idea to look back at
what kind of knife was used to cut Seth
Baxter's jigsaw piece what kind of oil
was left behind by Strom's fingerprints
are really any reason to doubt that one
of the tapes was recorded by someone
other than John at the beginning of this
video I discussed the recurrence of the
number six because this was the sixth
mood
the original saw saga was released in
consecutive years from 2004 to 2010
ending with saw seven technically saw 3d
but I call it's awesome that was
originally gonna be the last movie so it
was given an alternate name saw the
final chapter now in saw six at the
Umbrella health company William Easton's
desk is where all contract disputes come
to an end he even tells John when he
comes in to plead his case about getting
coverage for the gene therapy buck stops
here drawing far away
so basically we're being told that
whatever it is it stops at mr. Easton's
death and on mr. Easton's desk at all
times is these dots which add up to the
number seven okay big deal there's some
dice they happened to add up to seven
there's seven movies it's probably
coincidence right well I was gonna say
the same thing but then I realized that
no matter what angle no matter what
scene in the movie the numbers facing
the camera always add up to seven which
means someone had to specifically go in
and move these dice every time the
camera moves in order to keep this
consistent
stops here and the series stops at 7:00
so make sure you join me for the next
episode of things you missed where I'm
gonna be covering the final chapter of
the initial yearly Saw movies salsa
remembers describe the sea zis worlds
for new horrors every week ring that
death battle for notifications and I'll
see you in the next one
assuming we both survive piranha yes
very good John very good